[Music]
on this friday night russian forces
expand their bombardments
the new air strikes into western ukraine
as russian forces close in on heave
and the hundreds of volunteers preparing
essential supplies anxiety about
retaliation as sanctions keep piling up
against russia they're going to try and
take the necessary steps to ensure that
the businesses are able to go forward
and the kremlin's latest false claims
about ukraine two years of the pandemic
what we have lost and what we have
learned and a haven for job hunters
candidates are getting multiple offers
the extraordinary lengths employers are
going to lure the best workers
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are lots of threads to the russian
war in ukraine tonight including signs
russian forces are widening their
attacks
the aerial campaign is now extending
further into ukraine targeting cities in
the west that until now have been free
of bombardment and satellite images of a
convoy of military vehicles that
appeared stalled near kiev
now show it's dispersed u.s and british
intelligence say it appears russian
forces are resetting and redeploying
russia has gained some ground the
sections in red on this map are areas
under russian control several cities
including harkev are encircled and the
arrows show where russian forces are
advancing including towards the capital
kiev
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
posted another video today he says it's
impossible to say how long it will take
but that the fight will be over soon
we've already reached a strategic
turning point he says we are moving
towards our goal towards our victory
mike armstrong is in western ukraine and
he begins our coverage tonight
the first attack of this war to hit the
city of lutsk came in darkness videos
posted to social media show multiple
large explosions just after 5 30 a.m
local time
city's mayor posted a message to
residents on facebook saying three
missiles hit near the airfield four
ukrainian soldiers were killed and six
injured
about an hour later 215 kilometers south
more missile strikes these ones in the
city of ivano frankevsk now it wasn't
the first attack for that city it was
also hit on the first day of the
invasion this was video of that strike
but since then things have been fairly
quiet the city's been a staging area for
supplies to be sent to the front in
eastern ukraine it's also been a safer
place for thousands who fled the
fighting
the mayor says two people were injured
no one was killed but he says the
missile attack wasn't just about the
airfield it was also about morale in
western ukraine
it's safe territory for ukraine and
that's why
russia
wants to
to have a panic in our
people
[Music]
now we've been asked not to show any of
the fortifications in the city's
downtown but we were invited into this
supply depot it's a group of volunteers
about 550 men and women running shifts
day and night
the group also has about 100 former
ukrainian servicemen something that
helps get the food and supplies directly
to the front even when there's danger
this man is one of the organizers in
recent years they've been shipping 20 to
30 tons of supplies every month in the
last two weeks they've shipped 600 tons
the russian defensive also expanded in
the east the city of denipro was hit for
the first time three missiles struck an
area around a chemical factory killing
at least one dinipro is ukraine's fourth
biggest city the major industrial hub
it's also another place where people
have gone thinking
it was safer
mike armstrong global news ivano
frankie's ukraine
a new life born in the midst of war this
is one of the women who was pictured
struggling down the stairs of that
bombed maternity hospital in mary opal
still dressed in the same spotted
pajamas she has given birth to a baby
girl who is said to be healthy the
situation in mary opal ukraine says is
now critical russian forces continue to
relentlessly bomb the city ukraine says
almost 1600 civilians have died and
those who are still alive have been
without power or water for more than a
week attempts to take the capital have
so far failed russia is now changing
tactics and the country's defense
minister told vladimir putin today
everything is going to plan
jackson prescott reports
russia's military released video
claiming to show its forces moving near
ukraine's capital where residents are
shoring up defenses stocking up and
preparing for an invasion target is
capital of ukraine target is key
we are ready to defend our city the
remarkable strength of the ukrainians
and stalled russian advances have left
keeve relatively untouched that likely
won't last this is going to be an
extremely brutal battle if russia
decides to hold sword of the siege and
try to move in force
desperation may drive increasingly
brutal measures from the kremlin
the risk of this is very real russia
summoned a meeting of the u.n security
council to warn without proof that
ukraine is planning biological or
chemical weapons attacks
false claims that could provide cover
for russia's use of such weapons against
ukraine today the world is watching
russia do exactly what we warned it
would and now putin is looking to expand
that war he met with the puppet leader
of belarus friday the ukrainians allege
that during that meeting russian jets
attacked belarusian villages another
false flag attack meant to draw moscow's
close ally into ukraine and that's why
belarus might be stepping in too they
need more forces to strengthen and carry
out this war of attrition the west now
has to decide how to respond to all
possible scenarios putin is an aggressor
he is the aggressor and putin must pay
the price
in washington president joe biden
announced a coordinated g7 and eu plan
to remove russia's favored nation
trading status and block more russian
imports he issued another stark warning
about moscow's alleged plans russia
would pay a severe price to use
chemicals
despite those threats nato remains
deeply wary of going too far in ukraine
and for the first time president biden
issued a dire warning about the
potential for a third world war if
there's spillover that leads to direct
conflict between nato and russia
donna
jackson in washington thank you
ukrainian officials say the mayor of the
southern city of melatopal has been
abducted by russian forces in a
statement ukraine's ministry of foreign
affairs says mayor ivan fedorov was
kidnapped earlier today after being
falsely accused of terrorism ukraine
calls it a war crime and calls on the
international community to help save his
life
russia is expanding control of the
information and the narrative of its war
it is restricting access to instagram
which has millions of users in russia
and it's opened a criminal case against
facebook's parent company meta meta
temporarily changed its hate speech
rules to allow facebook and instagram
users to call for violence against
vladimir putin and russian soldiers
meadow says it's making allowances for
forms of political expression that's not
how russia sees it russian prosecutors
plan to designate it an extremist
organization which would mean it would
be banned in russia whatsapp though is
still up and running because it's a
messaging platform not a social network
the canadian government is sanctioning
five more russian oligarchs who are
deemed to be enabling vladimir putin in
his war against ukraine they include
billionaire roman abramovich owner of
the chelsea football club and a man with
deep ties to canada's mining industry
abigail beeman explains
abramovic is one of russia's richest and
most influential oligarchs he owns the
chelsea football club the united kingdom
just moved to sanction him thursday now
canada follows abramovich is part owner
of steel company evraz it supplied the
majority of steel used to build the
trans mountain pipeline asked about the
sanctions impact for canadians trudeau
said the sanctions are targeted at
individuals i believe abramovic
owns shares that are worth a little less
than 30 percent of uh evraz um
we are obviously going to watch
carefully but we are confident that this
will not if impact the hard-working
canadians who
are doing good work in in companies
across the country it still isn't clear
what the full impact of the sanctions
will be in addition to the five
individuals trudeau announced new export
sanctions for 32 russian military
entities so they can't buy equipment
from canadians the list includes the
foreign intelligence service and
aircraft and helicopter companies we
need to continue to remain firm and
united
in
demonstrating our resolve
and our deep conviction
that vladimir putin has made a terrible
mistake
and will
end up
losing
despite how many bombs he can drop on
hospitals or perhaps even because of it
there is no win in this
for him
however long it takes trudeau has been
asked several times this week about how
canada can help europe with oil and gas
europe is dependent on russian supply
with many countries wanting to cut ties
trudeau was clearest friday saying
canada doesn't have the infrastructure
necessary to replace russian energy here
on european soil but is talking with
allies about what role canada could
potentially play going forward
abigail beeman global news warsaw
while the prime minister says canadian
sanctions against russian oligarchs will
have little impact here on companies
there are concerns the wealthy
businessmen might still be able to
retaliate jamie dahl reports
roman abramovich is a billionaire
businessman and former russian
politician with ties from vladimir putin
back to boris yeltsin he made much of
his fortune after the fall of the soviet
union he's also a shareholder in evras
the steel producer that employs more
than 1800 people in canada with three
production sites in alberta and one in
saskatchewan you need to have this
company function
because it's making all the pipe not
just for the trans mountain pipeline it
makes a fair amount of it but the oil
patch oriole patch as you know is is
doing better now and you need this pipe
uh in the you know in the short term i
guess to to complete a number of
projects abramovic owns 29 percent of
shares in the company britain has also
frozen his assets and 10 of the
company's board of directors have
resigned while both the company and
canada's prime minister tried to quell
any fear the sanctions could hurt
employees of evras in this country
others say there could be ramifications
it's hard to say with any certainty but
i have no doubt that they're going to
try and take the necessary steps to
ensure that the businesses are able to
go forward and that the oligarchs aren't
able to retaliate by say closing down
the business or or trying to hurt us in
in reality and retaliation and that of
course remains a possibility in a
statement saskatchewan premier scott moe
said his government is in contact with
ottawa and saskatchewan has been assured
the sanctions will not negatively impact
the mill there moe said he will continue
to engage with the federal government to
ensure that continues to be the case
alberta's energy minister says it's too
soon to say we have to probably wait and
see how that unfolds and wait to see how
some of these sanctions unfold before we
know the impact in alberta we're we have
started to look at all of the oil and
gas leases to determine if there is
russian ownership of of some of the oil
and gas wells in alberta and see what
can be done
about that nato leaders continue to
insist sanctions are making an impact
overseas
it's less clear just how the ripple
effects may be felt here
jamie dahl global news calgary
the family of saudi blogger rafe badawi
says he has been released from a saudi
prison ensaf hadar lives with the
couple's three children in quebec she
was granted asylum in canada after her
husband's arrest in 2012. she tweeted
today badawi is free in 2014 he was
sentenced to 10 years in prison and 1
000 lashes on charges he insulted islam
on his blog his family says the
conditions of his release are not yet
clear
the pursuit for the perfect employee
coming up the unconventional ways
companies are wooing workers
[Music]
statistics canada says unemployment is
now at pre-pandemic levels 337 000 new
jobs were added in february dropping the
unemployment rate to 5.5 percent
sectors hardest hit by covid19 like
restaurants and hotels have rebounded
adding 114 000 new jobs last month
there are now more jobs than people to
fill them and as ann gaviola reports
some companies are pulling out all the
stops to entice people to work for them
it's a job seekers market right now
across many industries levels of skill
and experience recruiters say the war
for talent is cutthroat and i have not
seen that kind of competition in that in
20 years it's really really tight
candidates are getting multiple offers
employers are taking unusual steps to
try to stand out food share toronto is
offering prospective workers 75 dollars
if they make it to the interview stage
because it's a labor labor-intensive
process
research there's a practicing there's
the the commute there's finding child
care the non-profit also offers hourly
compensation for assignments related to
hiring no freebies employers have to be
quite frank have been getting off
scot-free for a long time canada
currently has a high number of job
vacancies and relatively low
unemployment meaning more job openings
than not enough qualified workers to
fill them now this labor squeeze tends
to get worse as coveted restrictions
lift and right now recruiters say we're
in the midst of an ultra competitive
wave
this employment expert says interview
processes have gotten shorter so has the
time between a job interview and an
offer
the best are getting it done in a week i
certainly wouldn't advise any
organization to go beyond two weeks
companies aren't just listing a
position's duties and responsibilities
anymore they now have to sell themselves
as a great place to work the candidate
attraction process has changed greatly
and right now the employees or the
candidates are certainly the ones with
the power with gas prices at record
highs flexible work schedules are in
demand
the number one questions that we do get
asked all the time is can i work from
home for this position and they're
looking for a hybrid model workers who
aren't happy where they are have a lot
of opportunities in this environment and
the onus is on employers to be strategic
and do what they can to retain their
best and brightest or risk losing them
ann gaviola global news toronto
the conservative leadership race is on
ahead what direction will the party go
more candidates are lining up to take a
shot at the federal conservative
leadership four people have said they're
in the running so far including former
quebec premier joshere and ontario mp
pierre pauliev eric sorenson looks at
what it might take not just to win the
leadership but to win over voters
jean-charles the former progressive
conservative believes the current
conservatives must expand their appeal
and that he's the one to unite the party
and the country
this is something that we owe to the
citizens of the country
that is embedded in the history of our
party and that's to be a national
political party able to bring the
country together can cerrae repeat the
success of his former boss brian
mulroney who swept the country including
quebec which conservatives have not done
since
the rule is that usually quebecers will
tend to vote for a quebec leader would
it help to make inroads in quebec
absolutely
pierre poliev is a product of the modern
conservative party
this page
blacked out he torments the liberals and
promises a distinctly conservative
agenda the nepali f government will make
life more affordable by eliminating the
federal carbon tax on gas
heat and groceries this supporter
suggests poliev will appeal to social
conservatives and all conservatives
social conservatives just want to be
respected and hurt the winner of this
leadership will be the candidate who
appeals to the broader spectrum of party
members also joining the race this week
with this video mp leslie lewis who
placed a strong third in the last
leadership race the prime minister needs
to take responsibility for his failed
leadership so the field is taking shape
with poliev chara and lewis also running
ontario mpp roman babber and expected to
jump in this weekend brampton ontario
mayor patrick brown the former ontario
progressive conservative leader we are
deciding the future of this party and
potentially this country i think that
the party is at an inflection point
i think it's got to figure out
what direction it's going to go
conservatives are itching for another
crack at justin trudeau who has beaten
them three times but no prime minister
in a hundred years has won four
consecutive elections which means
canada's next prime minister could well
emerge from this bruising conservative
leadership race eric sorensen global
news toronto
next the losses and lessons after two
years of the pandemic
time has felt elastic since covet 19
dominated our lives so it's kind of hard
to believe it was two years ago today
that we led the newscast with this
good evening and thanks for joining us
the world health organization has now
confirmed what many epidemiologists have
been saying for weeks the coronavirus is
a pandemic all experts agree this is
going to get worse
well they were right of course
everything changed over the last two
years the virus is estimated to have
killed more than six million people we
have vaccines now and public health
restrictions are lifting it doesn't feel
like an emergency anymore but it's still
with us tonight jamie morocco looks at
what we've learned and are still
learning
for the first time since surviving
severe covet 19 last march matthew
cardinal went back to the regina
hospital that saved his life it was
hard for me to go to the hospital it was
very hard going to a place you're dying
basically
it was traumatizing left with long-haul
symptoms his future with the virus
remains unclear as so many others moved
to put this pandemic in the past the
direction we're going in now
i wouldn't say we're nearing the end but
i i think there are many ways in which
we can see the end that's not
necessarily the end of the world we
spend every day of our lives living with
viruses that once caused pandemics
influenza the 1918 spanish flu was the
deadliest pandemic on record but thanks
to herd immunity and medication it
fizzled out in the late 1980s there was
hiv aids but modern treatments have made
it a manageable disease
2009's h1n1 outbreak is often called the
forgotten pandemic thanks to technical
advancement surveillance and treatments
that quelled it so quickly montreal
microbiologist donald vin says really
only smallpox and possibly sars which
hit toronto hard in the early 2000s have
been eradicated what's likely going to
happen with stars cov2 may be similar to
what we saw with the 1918
influenza which is that
there was a peak amount of activity over
a certain number of years that
eventually decreased through a variety
of both viral biology and medicine and
public health measures leaving us to
coexist with covid to get there experts
say we can't repeat history we need to
focus on our failing healthcare systems
and build up capacity communicate public
health measures clearly to further avoid
pandemic fatigue put in place proper
data collection which we fail to
prioritize and continue to vaccinate
test contact trace and surveil
as much as many people want to believe
this is over this is not over
there will be subsequent waves the
question here is how and to what extent
will those impact us in canada the
answer may lie in what we've learned and
how we respond as a collective
jamie morocco global news toronto
well i never imagined two years ago that
we'd still be affected by the pandemic
it has been a long two years we leave
you tonight with a look back at some
moments
from paying tribute to healthcare
workers to the rollout of vaccines we've
all had to mourn to adapt to learn
and to live with a new kind of normal
that's global national for this friday
thanks for watching i'll see you on
saturday for the new reality take care
of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]